the illiterate Millennials of the New
York Times have published a five minute
long video essay titled please stop
telling me America is great just in time
for the 4th of July we will dissect the
nonsense then sargon of akkad stops by
to talk YouTube and politics
finally the mailbag and my favorite
soldier story from the Revolutionary War
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
just in time for the fourth of July the
New York Times comes out with a total
hit piece on not just some political
issue not just on Trump not just on
conservatives but on all of American
history and the American nation and they
call it an opinion piece so they say
it's an op-ed you know we're not
necessarily endorsing this view we're
just publishing it it's written
quote-unquote by someone named tej
Johnson and Naima Raza but the New York
Times can't distance themselves from
this entirely because it's not an essay
that these people wrote it's a video
essay this is something that was
produced at the New York Times it's a
five minute long video that they hired
someone to narrate it and they hired
people to illustrate it and animate it
and it goes through and it's just an
all-out attack on America and the idea
that America is great I mean there's
obviously an underlying message of the
of anti-trump ISM because President
Trump's campaign slogan is make America
great again Keep America great they're
saying America isn't great don't tell me
that America was great but they don't
talk about Trump they just talk about
the country here's how they launch their
attack America the greatest country on
earth a narrative packed and sold to
tiny Patriots reinforced by every
cartoon movie cheeseburger and mattress
sale guaranteed a mythology so
entrenched our most beloved
personalities are just never to question
it don't let anyone ever tell you that
this country isn't great that's right
now is the greatest country
greatest country God ever gave for the
greatest country in the world is the
greatest country in the world but what
if we did question it America is the
richest country in this club but were
also the poorest with a whopping 18
percent poverty rate closer to Mexico
than Western Europe twelve point eight
million American children live in
poverty
that's almost one in five of our kids
and speaking of kids turns out at the
level of high school science were 19th
of 36 reading 20th and math a dismal
30th we spend more in healthcare than
any other country in the golf club
especially out of our own private little
pockets but we live sicker and shorter
lives
we're fatter and globally we're more
likely to see newborns die we're even
behind Bosnia so I don't even know where
to begin with this with all of the
internal contradictions and the outright
nonsense the premise at the beginning is
that we're told never to question how
great America is when was the last time
that was true like 1952 all we are told
from kindergarten onward is that America
isn't great I mean now in our high
schools we are taught left-wing
anti-american polemics like Howard
Zinn's people's history of the United
States as though they were scholarship
as though they were regular old history
textbooks we're constantly
deconstructing America were knocking
down monuments I mean obviously we're
knocking down monuments to Christopher
Columbus we're knocking down monuments
to George Washington there's a school in
California about to spend about six
hundred thousand dollars to cover up a
mural of George Washington at a school
named after George Washington we're
always told that America isn't great the
thing that we're not learning is all the
great stuff that America has done but
then the New York Times goes in just in
those first few seconds to contradict
themselves several times we'll get to
that in a second but first if you are
not paying off your credit cards each
month you are paying hundreds if not
thousands of dollars in interest every
year
let Lending Club help you out with
Lending Club you can consolidate debt or
pay off credit cards with one fixed
monthly payment since 2007 Lending Club
has helped millions of people
gain control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trips to a bank no high interest credit
cards just go to Lending Club com tell
them about yourself and how much you
want to borrow pick the terms that are
right for you if you're approved your
loan is automatically deposited into
your bank account in as little as a few
days Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued
people especially guys get really lazy
about this III think that it's not that
they get behind on their credit cards
because they're terrible with money or
they're lazy or they're lazy and their
jobs I mean they're lazy in figuring out
their finances they don't want to figure
out how you can save so much money in
all those high interest rates by just
consolidating your debt it's don't yeah
if you're not gonna be lazy about your
job don't be lazy about your finances do
the smart thing and save a lot of money
go to Lending Club comm / Knowles Kanda
wles
check your rate in minutes and borrow up
to $40,000 that's Lending Club dot-com /
Knowles Keo wles Lending Club com /
Knowles canna wles all loans made by
webb bank member FDIC Equal Housing
lender so the premise of this whole New
York Times video is just demonstrably
false we are told by the pop culture
we're told by our educational
institutions we are told by the New York
Times itself the grey lady all the news
that fits the narrative that America
isn't great and they tell us that we're
told never to question how Great America
is I mean even Barack Obama the
President of the United States he said
he wants to fundamentally transform
America and he said he doesn't really
believe in American exceptionalism any
more than anyone else believes in the
exceptionalism of their own country but
then did you hear what they criticized
America for they criticized America for
being really poor well we're so poor
were starving then they also criticized
America for being too fat or obese they
they criticized America because our
babies are more likely to die apparently
than in some countries but then the New
York Times almost every day of the week
talks about how abortion is a sacred
right that we need to protect a
constitutional right to kill a million
babies
a year but it's terrible that some
babies die they criticize us for
spending the most money on health care
they say it's mostly out of our own
pockets too as if some money wasn't out
of our pockets when the government
spends money I guess the New York Times
thinks it comes from magic it comes from
thin air it doesn't come from our own
pockets of course government spending
comes from our pockets it comes from our
pockets through taxation then it is
inefficiently spent and there's a lot of
corruption usually along the way then
they spend it on health care
so they criticize us for spending a lot
of money on health care but we also have
the best health care system in the world
everybody who wants good health care
comes to the United States from every
other country if you want really the top
health care in the world you don't go to
Cuba
you don't go to Canada you don't go to
the UK you don't go to China you come to
America why because we have the best
health care system and it's not only for
the SuperDuper rich everybody in America
can get treatment and you don't have to
wait in long lines we don't have long
lines to wait for health care we don't
like the UK have a system where the
government just takes control of your
baby and if you want to get your babies
treatment for his condition like as in
the case of little baby Charlie guard or
baby Alfie the government in the US
can't just steal your baby from you like
the the socialist government the UK did
we have control over our health care
here also we lead virtually all of the
health care innovation in the world I
guess it comes at a cost but it's not
that bad we're all doing pretty well
here the New York Times then goes on to
talk about all of the immense flaws in
American democracy
zere America's lid on global rankings of
corruption and freedom and dropped from
a functional to a flawed democracy
I have to stop it there because the the
flaw in the New York Times's argument is
that America is a democracy we're not a
democracy
we're a republic the founders and
framers were terrified of direct
democracy they were terrified of mob
rule
that's why we have this brilliant
federal system this Republican system
that balances different rights different
authority different powers but
the federal government the state
governments the local governments
between the judiciary and the
legislature and the executive it's a
brilliant system but even beyond that I
was wondering when I saw them say that
the u.s. is falling behind were a flawed
democracy according to whom whose
opinion do I really have to value here
the answer is it comes from the
Economist Intelligence Unit
that's the Economist is in that leftist
magazine from the United Kingdom the
magazine that called ben shapiro an alt
right sage Orthodox Jew yarmulke wearing
ben shapiro is apparently a nazi
according to this outlet The Economist
so but I'm gonna trust their opinion
when it comes to American democracy and
by the way America's not even a
democracy were a republic and if we're
so stupid if we're so stupid we've
fallen behind on so many measures why do
we lead the world in everything in the
economy in culture in our political
system in our military we are number one
there is no number two we export all of
that around the world if we're so dumb
if we're failing at everything how is
that even possible
but then the New York Times totally
shows their cards they show what this
video is really about it's not about all
the flaws that America has it's not
about correcting mis-education it's
about something much more fundamental
we'll get to it in a second but first
let's talk about a little capitalism
because that's free enterprise has made
America great and cellphone plans and
bills are notoriously confusing it is
impossible to know what you're really
paying for all those hidden fees all
those charges and when you sign up it
doesn't seem like they're all those
charges but then when you get the bill
they all add up no more thanks to
wonderful free enterprise in competition
we have mint mobile mint mobile makes it
easy to cut your wireless bill down to
just 15 bucks a month and I know you
don't believe me because you've been
burned too many times on cell phone
plans so you know when you hear 15 bucks
a month you say yeah there's gonna be
all these extra charges though then
you're gonna have a $50 fee here and a
hey didn't no I'm telling you believe me
fifteen bucks a month that's what it is
I'm telling you the truth every plan
come
with unlimited nationwide talking text
with mint mobile stop paying for
unlimited data that you will never use
you can choose plans between 3 8 or 12
gigabytes of 4G LTE data you use your
own cell phone with any mint mobile plan
and you keep the same phone number along
with all your existing contacts ditch
your old wireless bill and start saving
with mint mobile the way the old
wireless companies do it is they charge
you for all this data that you're never
going to use so you have the illusion
that you're using all this data and
you're paying an arm and a leg for it
but you don't use it they never have to
part with it and it's just a way for
them to rob you blind Get Smart
ditch it to get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and get the
plan shipped to your door for free go to
mint mobile comm slash Knowles canna
wles that is mint mobile comm slash
Knowles Keo wles cuts your wireless bill
down to 15 bucks a month at mint mobile
comm slash Knowles so the New York Times
finally gives away their hand here
they go on to describe everything that
we do succeed in in America but it's all
terrible according to the New York Times
so what besides our economy and military
are we actually number one in so what
are we number one in now listen how they
bury the lead here right what besides
our economy in military are we actually
number one in the economy in the
military pretty important aren't they
the economy and the military are I don't
know though those are the main ways that
we judge nations around the world right
kind of glossing over some important
things in our economy and our military
aren't just slightly better than
everybody's they are a zillion times
better I mean they are there's barely a
second place GDP in the United States is
21 point five trillion dollars that's 51
percent larger than China's GDP 51
percent larger even though China has
four times our population there's an
extra billion people in China more than
an extra billion people in China and our
GDP still crushes them we also still
have the strongest military in terms of
military spending way more than twice
the next highest military spending
country which is China but as a matter
of military victories military power
that we project around the world you
couldn't even quantify it so pretty good
I mean it's funny they have to admit
that because otherwise it's just so
dishonest in their video but what did
they say they spent like four seconds
saying that then they move on they say
but besides that besides those two
incredibly important measures what else
are we number one in just a bunch of
totally bad stuff turns out a lot of
things civilian gun ownership mass
shootings TV watching prescription drug
abuse prison population oh and almost
number one an environmental damage edged
out by China okay
you see all of oh no it's so awful let's
just quickly debunk every single thing
they said first of all civilian gun
ownership is a very good thing it not
only protects us from bad guys it
protects us from tyranny from the worst
the worst series in the world have taken
away people's guns before they've
they've unleashed their worst miseries
on their people so civilian gun
ownership that is a plus it is good that
we have the number one in them mass
shootings yeah mass shootings are awful
Americans are also much much more likely
to be killed by hands and feet and clubs
and hammers than the types of guns that
are used in mass shootings so it's it's
awful when things happen it's it's sad
that in a fallen world bad things happen
but it's not even coming close to the
real issues here the vast majority of
gun crimes by the way are not mass
shootings or not ar-15
their pistols being used in suicides and
guess what if you take away the guns the
people who are going to kill themselves
you're just gonna find out another way
to do it a TV watching they mentioned
this is my favorite one they mention it
because they're talking about how awful
TV watching is in a medium that is being
viewed on a TV screen this is a video
essay so you're watching this on a TV
screen and they're telling you how bad
TV is if TV is so bad why'd you make the
essay why didn't you just use your words
and write it oh I forgot because the
Millennials who run the New York Times
are completely illiterate prescription
drug abuse now this one is very
important because it sounds bad it can
be bad but actually it it shows you a
wonderful aspect of America that
had just been complaining about earlier
we'll get to that in a second but first
we are so capitalistic today folks and
this especially oh my I'm so pleased but
I get to leave you for fourth of July
weekend telling you about purple
mattress you know how much I love purple
mattress red white and blue is the color
of this weekend what happens when you
mix them all together well you get
purple of course and it will feel
different than anything else you have
ever experienced because it's this new
technology it's not an innerspring it's
not a memory foam it's this new the
plasticy I don't even know what it is
it's made by a rocket scientist it's
it's both firm and soft at the same time
how is that possible I didn't I don't
know I can't tell you it just is now why
does it feel cool when you sleep on it
why does it why don't you get super hot
at night I don't know I'm not a rocket
scientist I was so skeptical of this
mattress I listen I'm conservative I
don't like change okay I was perfectly
fine on my old mattress or so I thought
I tried out purple for one night and I
have become a proselytizer for purple
man I love this thing so much I talk
about it like two or three times a week
just a sweet little Lisa on the bed
you're gonna love it hundred night
risk-free trial if you were not totally
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund backed by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns free
and home set up an old mattress removal
you will love purple and right now my
listeners get a free purple pillow with
the purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to all the great free gifts
they're offering site-wide how do you do
it just text Noel's Cantor wles
to eight four eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is to text
knowles KO wles to eight four eight
eight eight KO wles to eight four eight
eight eight message and data rates may
apply so then they go on in the new york
times they criticize prescription drug
abuse
yeah prescription drug abuse is awful it
also means that we have a highly
functioning healthcare system where the
problem is not that there's too little
medicine for too few people it's that
there's too much medicine for too many
people obviously you want to stop
prescription drug abuse as best you can
you want to stop bad doctors from over
prescribing but prescription drug abuse
is the sort of problem that you get in a
healthcare system that is actually
suffering from abundance not scarcity
we're suffering from too much health
care not too little prison population
they say this like it's a bad thing
sometimes conservatives fall into this
trap to a large prison population means
that we are locking up our criminals
that's a good thing when we had a lower
prison population in the early 90s and
late 80s we had a lot more criminals on
the street committing a lot more violent
crimes now we have many more people in
prison and a much lower crime rate good
thing lock him up lock more of them up I
want I want more prison a greater prison
population so we have lower crime and
then environmental damage this is just
BS you can just take the Paris deal as
an example we pulled out of that Paris
climate deal and we are leading the
world in reducing carbon emissions in
2017 u.s. carbon emissions declined by
more than 42 million tons now what's
bizarre about this is that Canada Spain
the EU and China who were all
signatories of the Paris deal they are
they're really serious about taking care
of the climate they actually increased
their carbon emissions New York Times
doesn't talk about that though so we
pull out of these stupid and do-nothing
deals and we actually lead the world on
the environment the New York Times
doesn't even come close to making an
argument that America isn't great what
they do is show that they don't like
America they just don't like it they
don't like the things that make America
great they don't like the ample Liberty
that we enjoy they don't like the
freedom to own guns the freedom to watch
TV the freedom to purchase medications
and the freedom to eat the food that we
want they don't like any of that they
want to shut it down well that doesn't
mean America isn't great that means that
the New York Times isn't great and I
think it never was we have got to get to
now a fabulous guest one of the biggest
names on YouTube Sargon of Akkad Korell
Benjamin if there's somehow that you're
living under a rock you've never heard
of him
take a look you're normalizing this kind
of language here I'm normalizing
accommodate you because at this point
comedy is under attack in this country
here is me I'm balling Inventure a joke
I can name other comedians who are being
investigated for jokes we have gone down
a very dark path as all well says
printed on the front of this building
if Liberty is to mean anything at all it
must mean the right to tell people that
which they don't want to
you do you sound like or not this is the
BBC does the BBC stamp buy that or not
here is some comments from your social
media take it honestly for me I'm not
gonna speak for you clip as a whole but
for me being able to table these issues
around free speech is the most important
thing I'm a free speech activist we have
we are losing our ability to make jokes
in this country
what about there's a puritanical moral
standards I don't promote the language
of rape imbalance I make jokes do you
agree all the ones decontextualize on
this and no that's tyrannical that's
tyrannical that is the state of the
mainstream media right now and that's
the state of big tech right now but at
least they haven't shut us down yet
Sargon of Akkad Karl Benjamin's so nice
to meet you my friend I'm so glad you
could come by in studio oh thank you now
a real pleasure of course I've seen a
lot of your videos but you know I wanted
to refresh I wanted to see what people
are saying about you now so I looked up
some articles in BuzzFeed you know the
best place I mean in the New York Times
and I learned I didn't know this about
you you are an all right white
supremacist Nazi did you know that it
actually yes I yeah so of course since I
read it in the New York Times of course
it has to be true right from page wow
that was the great thing I mean I didn't
realize how such big news
how does this happen I mean you go from
being one of the biggest names on
YouTube and your big issue is free
speech I mean you learn politically
incorrect guy you say plenty of
outrageous things you said you make
plenty of jokes yes and they try to turn
you into a Nazi how did it happen why
did it happen it happened exclusively
and it happens to anyone who challenges
the progressive left and the dominance
for political correctness across the the
political sphere of society
that's the exclusively the reason they
do it and they will continue doing it
until eventually people just stop
listening to them and I can't think of
any other way for it to end
really I mean we can't censor them out
of existence obviously so what other
options do we have but they can censor
us out existence I mean that's my
favorite yes they can but that's because
they're Nazis right
call me a Nazi if they're gonna they're
gonna say they're anti-fascist yes
marching around literally wearing black
shirts the uniform fascists using
violence against civilians for political
ends yeah but I do have a real fear
about this because you have you still
have one of the biggest channels on
YouTube for now for now mmm they
demonetized you and then they kicked you
off patreon so they kicked you off your
instrument of funding yourself yeah and
the what's worse as well is that they
are definitely D ranking us on youtubes
algorithms as well I can I can actually
see there's a very explicit visual
representation of this because YouTube's
give you the access to the information
on how people find your channel and
obviously a huge chunk of it is
recommended videos in the sidebar and
you can see that having is around May
the 1st they obviously altered their
algorithm because the traffic from that
just plummets and that's a huge amount
of traffic that comes to your channel so
yeah we're and this is not just
happening to me as having Dave Rubin
it's happening to Tim pull and this was
what their project Veritas
whistleblowers have been letting us know
and it's again and it's not new either
the these sort of whistleblowers like
James d'amour coming and saying well at
Google has a monoculture that actively
describes us and has the Veritas leaks
showed they describe us actually as
Nancy's they consider Ben Shapiro Dennis
Prager and Jordan Pete son to actually
be Nancy's dog whistling to other
Nancy's and I mean IIIi don't know where
to go with that because it's so
comically backwards well what I love
about the dog whistle claim is you know
I never hear these dog whistles now I
never hear them I'm not a dog so what
does that make them yes but when you got
kicked off patreon yes that actually did
spark a pretty big backlash it did
Jordan Peterson got off Dave Rubin got
off has it made any difference
not really because um oh well initially
initially yes and because that's the
sort of dirty tactic they go for patreon
zone rules and jack conte was very clear
about this when he was talking to Dave
Rubin
saying that we only care about we do on
Treon except when they get something
that they decide they want to take off
patreon which was you know none of this
was on patreon it was when I was having
a spat with a group of Nazis online
actual you know Nazis online and I was
calling the mean words and patreon the
side note you can't call them mean words
we we are concerned about the sanctity
of these Nazis and therefore you can go
and that wouldn't have been a problem
because there are alternatives there are
competitors to patreon because really
what they do it's it's very basic
service they just aggregate donations
and then take 5 cent cut but the the
interesting thing is I I said fine
that's not a problem you know you if you
if you for some reason wish to make up a
reason to kick me off your platform
that's fine I'll just use one of your
competitors and interestingly stripe the
payment processing company pulled out of
that competitor a day or two after I
announced that I was going on there now
that that to me is very peculiar because
this this competitor had been going for
about eight months prior to me joining
it with no problems whatsoever
suddenly I join it and now all notes oh
you can't have that so it looks like
it's effectively cartel behavior you
know this is the issue because I used to
have I mean would you describe yourself
as a conservative or more as a classical
than I describe myself as an English
liberal which I guess some is is a lot
closer to like your founding fathers
right it makes you know I I believe in
limited government freedom of action
right in inherent natural rights you
know nothing nothing that the Nazis
would agree with incidentally but this
is my issue is when I look at what
they're doing to to you I mean obviously
you're just a huge personality on
YouTube so they go for you yes but
they're doing it to me they're doing it
all of us here and I used to be so less
a fair about everything hands off don't
worry it'll work itself out yeah because
if look if one tech company isn't going
to let us on their platform yet another
one will accept they control the flow of
information around the internet and well
okay never mind
you know at least I can find a
competitor somewhere except the payment
processor is gonna be loud they're not
gonna at a certain point at gabba gabba
calm I mean you know you you can say
well gang comm has a lots of people who
have been censored on there so it does
contain neo-nazis and you know the the
really sort of the sort of people that
you don't act
you want to engage with politically
because you know what their ideas are on
their back they're a bad hombre
but they they have a right to speak like
anyone else and gab is not a platform to
promote that they also you know they
allow anyone to use it it's a free
speech dedicated platform and
unsurprisingly the sense of people go
there they they pulled gabs hosting
service they they would be hosted and
have to find another host probably
somewhere outside in the US outside of
Silicon Valley's tendrils you this is
not a fair market place this is not a
fair market place and the scales are
being deliberately waited as we know
from insight is leaking they that where
they are not actively deep platforming
people or entire platforms just for
hosting people that they don't like
because at the end of the day I mean I
don't have a criminal record or anything
you know that an England has hate speech
laws you know so if I had if I'd
actually done something and we're we're
very left-leaning country you know
they'd come down on me like an absolute
absolute hammer and and they'd nail me
on anything they could nail me on but
I'm still I'm still in the clear so
really this is all its kind of front
it's kind of a game of chess that's
being played I think and so yeah and it
is to the benefit of people who actually
do not consider us to be people's rights
that's the thing because the the as soon
as as soon as the left and one of the
best things we can do is to draw the
left out and get them to be censorious
because as soon as they start saying
okay you don't have a right to free
speech what they're saying is you aren't
a human as I recognize you to be you're
not a human as I am a human exactly
exactly we're looking at yeah they
actually have a two-tier system and then
when we get to the the software and Ino
and hit me you know you're not a
journalist you're not of this you're not
in that and so it doesn't matter you
know if you recognize the recognizing
machine being with inherent rights you
know you don't have a right to just
assault in multi-platform it or anything
these things you know that what you're
doing is and it's a display of power you
know that's the justification for it
it's not justified in principle it's
only justified because you have the
means and you have the motive and they
frankly they hate us I mean this I don't
know how else to say it they hate us
them the journalists so-called at The
Huffington Post New York Times wherever
yeah they more or less defended an Tifa
against and clearly openly I've seen
many of them
I mean the the huffington post posted an
article saying was that the the
far-right wanted blood at wherever the
location was and they got it it's like
no a and II know isn't far right I know
the man he's he's a very soft-spoken gay
he's quite progressive in many ways
lives in Portland you know he's part of
that culture so he's not he's not I
wouldn't even call him a conservative
really you know by your standards you
know it's interested sports free speech
he's very socially liberal you know
right um but yeah they will describe
them as far-right and they will say no
no it's completely acceptable to do this
and then you'll see they're talking
heads and their verified check mark Joe
knows on Twitter all all spouting the
same sort of thing and then when one or
two like someone like Jake Tapper steps
out of line and says well hang on a
second and and understandably so this is
clearly undermining the rule of law I
mean there's no there's no way you can
argue that it's not all they can resort
to as year well he's fascist adjacent
he's enabling fascist yes and it's like
all right all right because I mean if
we're if that's the standard then ante
far definitely enable fascists because
the fascists can go look at these
rampant communists who are beating
people up in the streets you know you
should listen to us and where does the
traffic go that's just adjacent this is
a new that's amazing rip you know I want
to ask you one last very important
question on this about where it goes
from here but before we do that I've got
a second by to Facebook and YouTube I
probably already said goodbye to YouTube
now that I have this guy on myself so
you've gone on you you've got to go over
to Daily wire calm ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you'll get
me you'll get the under Clavin sure you
get the men Shapiro show you'll get the
Matt Walsh show you'll get everything
you'll get the leftist here's tumblr I
you know what I don't want to rob I
don't want to rob the YouTube audience
of your answer to this question so I'll
go to the sub break after you answer
this now that they take away our
platforms they take away our payment
services they take away our everything
hmm how do we fight back do we start
another YouTube and then they take away
that too or do we have to use political
means to fight back there are there are
two ways of doing it honestly at the
moment the conservative
in the u.s. are in the driving seat when
it comes to political means and honestly
there's nothing wrong with using them
you know the none of this would go
against conservative principles as I
understand them yeah this is not a free
market it is not there is no fair
procedure and there is no Just Cause
behind it there is no method of appeal
either
so none you could not describe the way
that people like Tommy Robinson or Paul
Joseph Watson on Facebook the the way
these people are being treated is
monstrous and if we were if we I say we
and when I say we I mean just the people
who are not the radical left at this
point it you know the if the normal sort
of centrist people were to act in that
way to them they would be howling and we
would be rightfully in the wrong so
there's no question of it there's
there's every reason to look at Silicon
Valley as a cartel or a monopoly
something like that because these
platforms are I mean for example Paul
Joseph Watson because Instagram is owned
by Facebook he's removed from both
platforms in the same day even though
they've got different Terms of Service
even though he didn't actually break any
of the rules as they can show them
especially the same with Tommy Robinson
but it's a it's a it's an entire sweep
over any of the platforms that that
company owns you know it's not just on
that thing so they're obviously not
acting independently because they're
owned by the same company exact so
there's the I mean and this is just
demonstrably true so there's every
reason to think that antitrust laws can
be used in these regards I think failing
that there is also the option for the
Conservatives to actually do something
it but it has to be essentially root and
branch you know so they're gonna have to
start with their own their own search
engines their own payment process their
own their own platforms and build up to
what the what the and it's not under
main services it's not even what the
left has built because the left didn't
built this it co-opted this you know
Silicon Valley if you look at the the
the people running owning the Silicon
Valley tech giants they look like
they're frightened children they look
like they're on top of a beast that if
their own making they didn't realize to
turn into a monster and it clearly has
mean Mark Zuckerberg actually had to
make a principled defense of Holocaust
denial right before he got absolutely
smashed by the reaction from the rabid
left gang well hang on a second so yeah
look he doesn't say he agrees with them
but he believes they have a serious
conviction and should he be the arbiter
of truth well
left us pressured them into becoming the
arbiters of truth which is a rot from
the old idea was if someone has a stupid
idea let him say it and you can smack
him down and prove him wrong that's
content that's what we do you know
that's and that's what they should be
doing they should be like well great you
know Alex Jones a sesame ridiculous
we're gonna laugh at him and the whole
deal I was completely correct if
anything he was underplaying that one
there was telling trance but some that's
right but you ever know so there are
there are things that the right can do
but the the problem I think is the right
is generally quite libertarian and
principally so like it's a very strong
moral conviction and one I am genuinely
sympathetic to but I'm not a libertarian
because I do believe that the state has
a role this is exactly how I feel yeah
exactly right there is there is a role
for the state and I think that it is to
protect our rights and in the case of
the market the markets not a perfect
entity you know when you have a
competition effectively someone has to
win and if you want the competition to
keep going then you have to make sure
that the winner doesn't just monopolize
everything that you have and so there is
a there is a role in my opinion for the
state to intervene if something is
becoming demonstrably unfair in this
regard and I think it is you know I mean
like people are being deep at form for
not even breaking rules
the the Facebook one was the most
egregious one for Tommy Robinson in my
example because they they essentially
made up a bunch of things that Tommy had
not said and said that in the previous
months he had said you know kill all
Muslims and things like this it's like
if if Tom Robinson had posted that he's
under such scrutiny as such a large
audience we had such a large all the
audience that the second you saw that
you'd see the clip of that all the the
screen shot whatever it'd be everywhere
absolutely everywhere and he'd be in
jail he'd be in jail right he'd have it
you know because we have these laws in
the UK so the fact that they could just
make this up provide no evidence and
then shut down all of his accounts that
that to me is really concerned
terrifying and we're gonna have to shut
down your account right now over there
for you watching on Facebook and YouTube
we are gonna see each other later for a
cigar I hope is that right absolutely I
hope so all right excellent
I've gotta let you go now go to the sub
break but sargon of akkad obviously
they'll find you on YouTube then where
else can
good question I'm actually still on
Facebook and Instagram for now but there
are there are non Silicon Valley
alternatives like telegram and bit shoot
but I definitely recognize calm as well
alright telegram [ __ ] shoot - calm
whatever when they shut those down we'll
find a new one to find him on sargon of
akkad Karl Benjamin I'll see you later
on tonight you know
alright kiss go over to Daly wire.com
we'll be right back with the mailbag I
could talk to that guy all day we have
to get him back cuz there's so much more
I want to ask him about him he is one of
the most interesting guys on YouTube and
that's I think why they're going after
him so hard let's get to the mailbag
before I get to my favorite soldier
story from the American Revolution from
Michael Michael the change is for
someone who can win in 24 oh you're
talking this is you know what this is
this about the vice presidential pick
Mike Pence cannot win an election for
president if Republicans want to hold
the White House
they need someone dynamic I pray for MS
Rice Condoleezza Rice to change her mind
and get back in the game she's a true
leader with more knowledge than all the
candidates on both sides put together
change is good it shows courage and
leadership Republicans have to hold the
White House it is the only way to keep
the dam from breaking Cheers
Mikey G I feel you this is one of the
good arguments I guess for ditching pens
is he doesn't seem like an incredibly
strong presidential candidate however I
don't I don't really think that that is
cause to ditch him I think first of all
the presidential elections are about the
people running for president they're not
about the vice president they're not
about the next guy to run for president
they're not about the Secretary of State
they're not about any of that stuff
they're about the guy who's running for
president and I think right now if if
Trump ditches a loyal capable good
really good vice president conservative
vice president I think it it doesn't
look great I think it makes him look
ungrateful disloyal I'm not convinced
that it wouldn't scare some Christians
and evangelical Christians and everyone
else in the faith
freedom type coalition and in 2024
there's no reason the President Trump
has to endorse Mike Pence right away
Trump is his own guy I think he could
stand back and if it's gonna be Pence
and Haley and whoever else is running he
could say look pence was my VP he was
very good Haley was my UN Ambassador I'm
gonna sit this one out I in the spirit
of freedom I'm gonna let the Republican
voters decide who the nominee is gonna
be we've got so many great candidates
I'm so excited
Reagan's started to do this in 1988 he
it's not like he jumped on an endorsed
George Bush right away and maybe he
shouldn't have endorsed him at all
frankly because he was only a one-term
president I think it would be fine I
always caution conservatives against
playing seven steps ahead there were a
lot of people who told me we should vote
for Hillary Clinton in 2016 because then
the next election we would totally win
and it would be great
forget about the next election worry
about this election I think Trump should
stay loyal to his guy and keep keep the
coalition and keep the team united from
Chuck Michael do you think Judas went to
heaven after he died if not what hope is
there for us if someone that gave up
basically everything to follow Jesus
didn't make it
I make no pronouncements on who is in
heaven or hell
other than the Saints that we can we can
know that the Saints are in heaven it's
been revealed in the book of Revelation
but I I don't make proclamations over
whether I think so and so is in heaven
or hell generally speaking because it is
entirely possible that Judas could have
had repentance in his last fleeting
moment on earth and could be now before
the beatific vision I'm not convinced
that that is the case I suspect he is in
hell and the reason for that is Christ
says the son of man must be betrayed but
woe to the man who does it and that it
would be better for that man if he had
never been born so that seems pretty
unambiguous to me the other reason is
that Judas is not likely and held
because of the betrayal of Christ he's
in hell because he despaired hope is a
theological virtue and he lost all hope
and killed himself now he could have
repented
last moments on earth I don't see a lot
of evidence that he did some say because
he threw away the silver that he
repented but he threw away the silver
they killed himself so I'm I don't
really see that hope and if you don't
have hope you then you don't get to go
to heaven heaven is hope I mean a heaven
is where we hoped for something after
this death well if you if you throw your
life away if you kill yourself you you
clearly don't have that and so I think
it very likely seals Judas's fate but
I'm not willing to make any definitive
statement on it hey Michael big fan of
the show
the Pope recently changed the words to
the Lord's Prayer from and lead us not
into temptation - and let us not fall
into temptation the argument being that
God is not the tempter so why would he
lead us into temptation
however I've read the original text of
Matthew and it's much closer to the
first version of the prayer doesn't this
present a problem when the Pope is seen
to be infallible in matters of Scripture
thanks big fan of the show sincerely
Nick your your right your read of that
is right and the Pope's read of the
Lord's Prayer is not right but you're
wrong in what you think papal
infallibility is and it's a common
mistake people make it all the time the
Pope is not infallible in matters of
Scripture
the Pope is infallible when he is
speaking and that the term is ex
cathedra so when he is speaking from his
official office right people think this
happens every day every time if the Pope
woke up and said 2+2 is 5 we would have
to believe it no the Pope can be wrong
about a number of things and the Pope's
frequently are wrong about a lot of
things papal infallibility has only
occurred guess how many times in the
history of the Catholic Church Catholic
Church has been around 2,000 years how
many times twice twice the Pope has
speaking in spoken infallibly and it was
to clarify questions about Mary which
had been which also were not his random
ideas but had been building up for well
over a thousand years in the Catholic
Church I looking on the bright side when
the Pope gets something wrong which
Pope's frequently do I think it
is actually a good reminder because the
Pope is he's the the primary bishop you
know he's the successor to Peter but
he's also a bishop
he's bishops get things wrong the
bishops in the United States get things
wrong a lot it's good to remember that
the Pope is fallible except when he's
infallible I want to get to very briefly
before we go my favorite American
history figure from the Revolution this
guy I always try to write down a few
notes about him here is Samuel
Whittemore Samuel Whittemore born on
July 27th 1696 he's an American farmer
and soldier he's the oldest known
colonial soldier in the Revolutionary
War
he according to some sources obviously
there are little scarce fought in King
George's War in 1744 he fought in the
French and Indian War in 1754 then he
fought in the American Revolution in
1775 on April 19th 1775 Samuel
Whittemore he's in the fields he's
outside of Lexington and Concord the
British are marching toward Lexington
and Concord and this guy loads up his
musket and he takes a shot and he kills
a British soldier so he's behind a stone
wall at this point he then turns takes
out his dueling pistols and shoots again
kills another British soldier mortally
wounds a third British soldier he then
fires off another shot but by that point
the British had finally made it to him
so Samuel Whittemore throws his guns
down draws his sword and starts
attacking them so he's attacking and
these British must have thought what is
this insane American doing 78 years old
he the British then shoot him in the
face so they blow his face up they
bayonet him numerous times they leave
him for dead in a pool of his own blood
so that's the end of Samuel Whittemore
right no the Patriots come up and they
see him lying there it is this mangled
body of a man but he's not lying dead
he's trying to reload his gun to fire
off another shot so they pick up this
crazy old American man they dragged him
down to the doctor doctor cotton Tufts
of Medford and the
doctor said there is no chance that he
would survive so what do you think
happened yeah he lived another 18 years
and died of natural causes at the age of
96 what an American that is the spirit
of the 4th of July I hope that you will
ignore the New York Times I hope you
will ignore Nike shoes which is now
getting rid of American flags that Betsy
Ross flag that we have behind us I hope
you go out there and shoot off fireworks
and eat hot dogs and hamburgers and
drink a lot of beer and make a toast to
Samuel Whittemore I know Brett Kavanaugh
certainly it's gonna say a toast right
he likes beer we all like beer
happy fourth of July I'm gonna be
subbing in for Ben on the radio today so
if you want three more hours come on
over there in the meantime I will see
you after Independence Day I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knoll Joe
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkiss and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Jeshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 hey guys over on the Matt
Walsh show today colin kaepernick as
you've heard is offended by the flag and
he thinks it stands for racism and
slavery
well it sounds sort of cliched to say it
but but in all seriousness I mean at
what point if you feel that way about
the country at what point do you leave
in search of a of a country that is not
so terrible and racist and all of that
also a congresswoman says that it should
be illegal to make fun of politicians
and some people online are pointing out
that Kamala Harris is not
african-american
where we're now told that it's racist to
point that out
but why would that be racist well try to
figure that out today over on the Matt
Walsh show